l'afrique est prise en otage il s'agit
de la guerre de la russie contre nous il
ne s'agit pas d'une crise c'est une
guerre brutale
avez vous entendu tout cela de la part
de vos partenaires russes avec qui vous
êtes restés en contact je suis persuadé
qu'ils vous disent tout le contraire
mais il faut dire qu'ils ont besoin de
cette crise qui maintiennent sciemment
délibérément ils se servent de vous ces
sanctions ne sont là que pour empêcher
la russie de nous réduire en esclaves
première et l'ins qui a voulu passer un
message à l'afrique bruno daroux est
avec nous bonsoir bruno quel est le
message finalement du président et
craignant voit qu'ils justifient les
sanctions parce que les africains ne
comprennent pas ces sanctions de
l'occident oui enfin le message sur
toulon là aussi un peu entendu la cc de
dire aux pays africains dont on sait que
certains se sont rapprochés de moscou
ces dernières semaines où ces derniers
mois de leur dire en fait vladimir
poutine il est en train de vous prendre
en otage avec cette crise alimentaire
puisque effectivement beaucoup de pays
africains sont dépendants du blé il ya
aussi d'ailleurs le problème des engrais
qui ne font plus exporter et ça c'est
presque un problème plus important
notamment en afrique subsaharienne parce
que évidemment ça a un impact sur la
production agricole donc
venir zelensky à volodine aux aînés ce
qu'il essaye de le redire réfléchissez
bien il sait très bien que le président
macky sall qui exerce la présidence de
l'union africaine actuellement s'est
rendu à sotchi il ya quelques jours il a
rencontré vladimir poutine alors ils
essayent de faire comprendre au
président russe qu ils ont besoin
absolument de ce blé de cet engrais et
que tout cela soit débloquée et
effectivement il appuie un peu la
demande de vladimir poutine de lever une
partie des sanctions pour débloquer
cette crise alimentaire alors justement
ces négociations difficiles dont parle
volodymyr zèle inscrits actuellement en
cours pour débloquer les ports d'ukraine
ya c'est en tout cas ce qu'indique le
président ukrainien de quelle
négociation par le til pas de
négociation qui
on n'avance pas vraiment pour l'instant
et qui implique évidemment
délégation ukrainienne russe et turc
puisqu'en fait la turquie c'est elle qui
a le le point d'entrer en mer noire avec
le détroit du bosphore et le détroit des
dardanelles la turquie voudrait faire
office de médiation mais pour le moment
évidemment les positions des ukrainiens
et des russes sont irréconciliables
puisque les russes disent nous on veut
bien lever le blocus qu on a en mer
noire si vous les ukrainiens vous
enlevez les mines qui protège
actuellement le port d'odessa et les
ukrainiens 10 buts et nous on va pas des
mines et les autour donné ça parce que
on vous fait pas confiance et s'ils ont
fait ça on sait très bien que vous allez
lancer l'assaut sur odessa donc pour le
moment les négociations qui sont un peu
au point vraiment merci beaucoup bruno